moment où l'on fait des bilans de
l'année on va aborder maintenant un
domaine où la recherche a fait des pas
de géant en 2015 mais sans faire les
manchettes c'est le monde de
l'intelligence artificielle des progrès
qui inquiète plusieurs lillers et pas
les moindres bonsoir mathieu censé lui
alors d'avoir aidez nous à comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'on leur tend exactement par
intelligence artificielle de plusieurs
types d'intelligence artificielle mais
vraiment ce qui est très tendance en
2015 c'est ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
de neurones artificiels donc qui copie
un peu la manière dont on dont on pense
et donc on est littéralement en 2015 en
train d'apprendre aux machines à
apprendre
on appelle ça le diplôme ning us avec
tout le monde
par exemple google est passé de projets
de recherche qui implique l'intelligence
artificielle de quelques années on avait
quelques dizaines
aujourd'hui on est à 2700 et ça c'est de
même un peu partout dans toutes les
entreprises de nouvelles théories ya des
gens qui s'inquiètent notamment de ces
développements absolument il irrite
masquant fondateur de paypal fondateur
de tesla
il vient d'annoncer qu'il allait
consacrer un milliard de dollars un
centre de recherche sans but lucratif
consacré à l'intelligence artificielle
ça s'appelle open et aillent donc
intelligences artificielles ouvertes et
donc lui son pari c'est de dire écoutez
on peut pas stopper la recherche là
dedans observé l'an dernier il avait dit
que les programmes intelligents ce
artificielle lui faisait part il dit on
va perdre le contrôle de sa comprend un
peu quand même
oui mes amis dans ces policiers par an
qu'on pourrait le penser a priori lui
dis plutôt que de laisser des
entreprises privées faire leurs propres
recherches on va aux finances et de la
recherche donc en mode ouvert et donc
les avancées seront accessibles à tous
donc échu can't beat them jump c'est un
peu son pari il était suivi là dedans
récemment par facebook et google qui ont
annoncé eux aussi tlr rendre les
résultats des résultats de leur
recherche a ouvert à tous donc on voit
grand qu'une tendance qui se développe
dans ce domaine remy n'empêche est ce
qu'on doit ou non s'inquiéter de tous
ces développements toutes ces avancées
là oui et non d'une certaine manière il
ya des aspects comme militaire où il
faut quand même
se dire que ça pourrait avoir des
impacts négatifs en des robots autonomes
qui décide de tirer sur des gens pas sûr
que les gens veulent savez de toute
manière dans le domaine de de l'allalin
de la reconnaissance d'image on a fait
des pas de géant mais ça c'est bon pour
pour tout le monde
reconnaissance d'image par exemple les
saignements quatre ans on avait des taux
d'erreur chez les machines de 25% pour
identifier les images aujourd'hui on est
à moins de 4%
même chose pour la reconnaissance vocale
les assistants vocaux en syrie cortona
tout ça maintenant la puissance de
calcul phénoménale du cloud computing
l'infonuagique dans de grandes fermes de
serveurs qui vont traiter votre voix qui
vont la comprendre on est dans le web
sémantique mais maintenant c'est de
savoir des impacts au bout de nos doigts
donc ça rend nos téléphones beaucoup
plus à l'écouté de ce qu'on fait ici on
peut dire d'une certaine manière que je
suis bonne nouvelle
bonne nouvelle possible par an que ce
oui parce qu'on va on entend parler 2016
merci beaucoup mathy plaisir sedin